R Richard Genest aurait-il pu
êêtre sauvé?
LeLe chirurgien qui l'attendait
àà l'hôpital d'Amos affirme
ququ'une prise en charge
cicinq minutes plus tôt aurait
chchangé la donne,
LeLes propos sont rapportés dans
lala lettre écrite par la mairee
dede Senneterre et à la lettre
enenvoyée au ministre Christian
DuDubé. Il a aussi décliné notre
ininvitation.
EsEst-ce bien le cas? À quel pot
lala condition de M. Genest
nénécessitait-elle
unune intervention rapide?
OnOn en discute avec le
DrDr Frédéric Jacques, chirurgin
cacardiaque et membre de
l'l'exécutif de l'Association ds
chchirurgiens cardiovasculaires
etet thoraciques du Québec.
BoBonsoir.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On peut t comprendre la
sisituation. Vous n'avez pas vue
papatient. Ce n'est pas un
didiagnostic, mais les deux
leles faits, des douleurs dans
l'l'après-midi dans la journée,l
vovoulait consulter en fin
d'd'après-midi il pense que la
pipierre aux reins. C'est surtot
didiagnostiqué d'une certaine
mamanière. Il démarre vers cinqu
sisix heures le lendemain matin.
DoDonc il y avait des symptômes
d'd'une fissure de l'aorte?
- - Oui. Habituellement ce qui
ararrive dans le contexte d'une
mamaladie de cet ordre, c'est qe
l'l'aorte sous-jacente est déjà
mamalade. Il y a un problème avc
lala paroi de l'aorte, pour les
gegens à la maison, l'aorte, c't
lala plus grande artère du corp.
C'C'est l'artère qui part du cor
etet qui amène le sang dans tous
leles organes.
HaHabituellement, cette artère
dodoit être dilatée d'un certain
dedegré, et à ce moment, la pari
vava être plus fragile. Il peuty
avavoir une fissure, comme l'avt
mementionné, cette fissure, si
elelle est importante et qu'on
enenseignement autour de l'aorte
cocomme telle, elle peut être
cocontenue par les tissus autant
pependant un temps. À ce moment,
onon a une fenêtre d'opportunité
popour agir parce que souvent
c'c'est un peu comme les
trtremblements de terre. Il y an
pepetit séisme initialement, etn
auautre plus important palace.
C'C'est un peu la même chose. Iy
a a une première douleur qui est
momoins importante et par la sue
lala deuxième de l'art peut être
fafatale.
QuQuand les gens ont ce type de
dodouleur, ils doivent se
prprésenter pour qu'on puisse
inintervenir.
- - Les premiers symptômes était
mamal de dos. Ma demande aussi.
QuQuand l'ambulance arrive,
l'l'abdomen est bleu. Il veut
coconsulter vers 5h30. L'urgence
esest fermée. Est-ce qu'une
ururgence avec des infirmières
auaurait pu voir le patient et
prprendre toutes les précautions
etet dire qu'on appelle
l'l'ambulance et qu'on les
prpriorise parce qu'elle a appeé
lele soir, et n'était pas la
prpriorité. Il a peut-être malgé
sasa situation. Est-ce que ça
auaurait pu jouer en sa faveur t
lului sauver la vie?
- - Comme vous l'avez mentionné
dadans l'introduction je ne
coconnais pas les détails ni dea
sasanté du patient et de
l'l'organisation de l'architecte
dudu système de santé en Abitib.
PaPar contre, ce qui est certai,
c'c'est que c'est une condition
ququi doit être prise en charge
rarapidement. Ce qu'il faut
sasavoir, c'est que 115 % des
papatients qui ont des maladies
ararticle le savent pas. Ils sot
asasymptomatiques. Il y a
seseulement une certaine portion
ququi vont savoir par des exames
anantérieurs, elle va avoir été
dédécouvert lors d'examenss ou
d'd'une échographie abdominale.
CeCes gens vont être capables, s
vovont s'être faits dire c'est e
dodouleur dans le thorax, dans e
veventre, présente toi rapidemet
àà l'hôpital parce que ton aorte
esest dilatée. Pour tous les
papatients qui ont une aorte qui
nene savent pas être dilatée,
c'c'est bien difficile de mettre
lele doigt sur le bobo.
- - La fenêtre pour sauver
ququelqu'un, il a quand même véu
dede sa première douleur de
l'l'après-midi jusqu'au lendeman
mamatin.
OnOn a une petite fenêtre. Chace
cocompte. Vous les vivez pas tos
leles jours mais très souvent?
- - Exactement.
LaLa fenêtre d'opportunité qu'oa
esest assez restreinte. Une fois
ququ'on a identifié la première
dodouleur, on sait que la deuxie
vava être grave. À ce moment,
popour la rupture d'une telle
dodouleur, il y a 90 % des gens
ququi n'iront pas à l'hôpital.
MaMais pour les personnes
cocoopérer, il y a le proportion
foforte qui va être arrivée trop
tatard. Il faut réagir très
rarapidement.
JeJe vais vous donner un exempl.
J'J'étais en train d'opérer une
chchirurgie cardiaque e à l'hôpl
etet un patient s'est présenté à
l'l'urgence, donc on parle en
viville, la patience est présene
àà l'hôpital universitaire je
trtravaillais et on m'a presque
sosorti de la salle d'opération
papar le collet pour l'amener ds
l'l'autre salle parce que le
papatient présent une rupture. e
fofois que le diagnostic est po,
ilil faut agir vite. Dans les
cicirconstances où un patient a
dédéjà une rupture, on peut même
êêtre obligé d'amener le patient
enen salle d'opération avant mêe
avavoir pu faire un examen.
PaPas d'échographie, pas de sca.
C'C'est le patient n'a pas de
rérétention, on sait que le
papatient a eu mal au ventre,
dedes fois ça peut être une prie
enen charge qui est plus rapide.
- - L'abdomen bleu. On s'y qu'ia
fafait une ambulance il restait
l'l'hôpital et on a changé
d'd'hôpital, encore beaucoup de
roroute. La question c'est : les
gegens en région avec des urgens
fefermées se demandent si ils st
prpris avec un système de santé
inincapable de répondre à ce gee
dede réponse.
EsEst-ce qu'il y a des régions à
ririsque?
- - Il y a beaucoup d'essais ete
coconditions de la question que
vovous me posez. Une fois de pl,
jeje ne connais pas les
paparticularités du cas
- - La condition clinique doit
êêtre prise en charge rapidement
avavec les personnes les mie